to Sochi at the beginning of the week, on Monday, at the invitation of Mr. Putin,
I talked to him about this issue in detail once again. In
Russian, as Qatar and Turkey, we attach importance to the
processing and delivery of one million tons of grain to African countries suffering from food shortages, by working together,
hopefully
we will achieve this.  The
issue is that
a process that excludes Russia is
very unlikely to be sustainable.
I am not hopeful that the grain corridor will become functional again. This process
can start again, but he
has a letter for ghusl. We will have a request from him to send
a second letter updating this letter.
This is about both insurance and swift.
As we
update this, there may be a new development here.
We will follow this as well
[Music]